Schweben im Dreivierteltakt.
In dieser Tanzschule mitten in der
Hauptstadt Österreichs
wird eine Wiener Tradition an die
nächste Generation weitergegeben.
Der Wiener Walzer wurde im
18. Jahrhundert zum Modetanz in Wien
und wird noch heute auf Bällen und Partys
in der ganzen Stadt getanzt.
Ehrlich gesagt,
ich wollte immer schon so tanzen können
wie all die Prinzessinnen bei Walt Disney.
Und ich bin hier, um das zu lernen.
Beim Walzer bin ich der Meinung
ist es für beide entweder gleich leicht
oder gleich schwer, je nachdem,
was für ein Typ man ist,
ob man sich leicht tut mit der Musik
und den Schritten oder schwer.
Der Walzer hat für mich etwas Wienerisches.
Es ist eine Wiener Tradition,
und es macht natürlich auch Spaß
und es ist auf Bällen eigentlich
einer der meist getanzten Tänze
auch gleichzeitig.
Ich finde ihn einen sehr harmonischer Tanz.
Er repräsentiert Österreich,
und er gehört zu unserer Kultur
wie das Wiener Schnitzel.
Wenn Sie irgendwo Walzermusik spielen,
es beginnt ja jeder sich sofort zu bewegen,
und man kann einfach nicht anders.
Mit 60 Takten pro Minute gehört
der Wiener Walzer
zu den schnellsten Tänzen der Welt.
Sein Name wurde erstmals Ende
des 17. Jahrhunderts erwähnt.
Damals etablierte sich der Walzer
als Gesellschaftstanz
und wurde auch von den Bürgerlichen
getanzt.
Er begeistert bis heute jung wie alt -
und das weltweit.
Dass der Wiener Walzer so beliebt ist,
hat verschiedene Gründe.
[Er] ist rhythmisch, lässt sich gut tanzen.
Rechts wie links rum, sag‘ ich jetzt mal.
Ich finde die Musik so schön.
Ja, das ist einfach schön,
so im Dreivierteltakt
und das passt zu uns und ja...
Wir tanzen einfach gern Walzer.
Mit seinen Kompositionen machte er
den Wiener Walzer
zum internationalen Exportschlager:
Johann Strauss.
Der Musiker und Komponist schrieb
Klassiker wie
„An der schönen blauen Donau“,
und er hat überall in Wien seine Spuren
hinterlassen.
In diesem Museum ist sein Werk
und das der gesamten Strauss-Dynastie
dokumentiert.
Helmut Reichenauer hat das Museum
mitbegründet.
Der Pianist und Musikforscher hat
viele Jahre seines Lebens
die Geschichte der Familie Strauss studiert,
die so viele große Musiker
hervorgebracht hat.
Der Durchbruch, den verdanken wir schon
Johann Strauss‘ Vater.
Um 1830 hat er Konzertreisen nach England
und nach Frankreich unternommen
und mit seinen Walzern
größtes Aufsehen erregt.
Johann Strauss Sohn hat dann diesen
Walzer noch in der Form perfektioniert.
Auch dessen Bruder Josef war maßgeblich
daran beteiligt,
und bei den Söhnen wurde der Walzer
in seiner Form noch vergrößert.
In sieben Räumen werden zahlreiche
Originaldokumente gezeigt.
Johann Strauss Sohn wurde 1825 geboren
und komponierte fast 500 Werke.
Nicht weit vom Museum entfernt ist die
Wiener Staatsoper,
die jedes Jahr Schauplatz des
Wiener Opernballs ist.
Er wird traditionell mit einem
Wiener Walzer eröffnet.
Besonders viel getanzt wird er natürlich,
der Wiener Walzer, auf den Wiener Bällen.
Bei diesen Ballfesten,
von denen wir etwa 450 pro Jahr haben –
also praktisch jede Woche, außer Juli
und August finden hier Ballfeste statt.
Da wird immer Walzer getanzt,
vor allen Dingen schon bei der Eröffnung
gibt es immer diesen Eröffnungswalzer.
Und damit der gelingt, heißt es
üben, üben, üben.
Wiens Tanzschulen scheinen
keine Nachwuchssorgen zu haben.